- [Narrator] This is a golden mantella.
They're critically endangered
and only found in a mere four square miles
in part of east central Madagascar.
At only one inch long, this little one
is actually fully grown,
but what they may lack in size
they make up for in color.
Their mildly toxic skin is bright yellow,
orange, and sometimes red.
Golden mantellas are insectivores,
feeding on termites, fruit flies,
and a range of other insects.
Although they have very
few predators in the wild,
they've been over-collected
for the pet trade.
They're endemic to swamps with
elevations close to 3,000 feet
but rapid deforestation
of their unique habitat
has left them critically endangered.
This is the golden mantella.